♪♪
(Crowd noise)
(Whistle blows)
(Knocking on door)
Howdy, y'all.
(All)
Ted!
What do you say to a cocktail,
Coach Lasso?
Oh, the same thing I'd say to
Diane Sawyer, if she ever asked
me out on a date. Yes, please.
Hahaha.
♪♪
Announcer:
Live from the Dog track, it's
Richmond with eight straight ties.
How many more matches
before you hit the panic button?
There's two buttons I never like
hitting. That's panic and
snooze.
♪♪
Ted:
I don't care what our record is.
It's all about believing that
everything is going to work out
in the end. Exactly as it's suppose to.
Ted:
Isn't the idea of "never give
up" one of them things we always talk about in sports?
Ted:
And shouldn't that apply to
people too?
It's a beautiful metaphor for
many of life's journeys.
♪♪
The teams just a little unlucky,
that's all.
♪♪
I think we should bring in
a sports psychologist.
Brought you a little, somethin'
somethin' for your first day of
work here.
I don't eat sugar...
Really? I've never met someone
who doesn't eat sugar.
Only heard about them, and they
all live in this godless place
called Santa Monica.
♪ Sing it ♪
♪ We will, we Will ♪
(Crowd cheers)
♪ Rock you ♪
You gotta fever for the flavor
of little girl talk, don't you?
This chap I've been seeing,
John.
Stamos?
No. His names John
Wingsnight.
Like at a sports bar, like
"Monday night's wings night,
down at PJ Flats".
Would you please stop?
Rule number 1. Even though it's
called girl talk, sometimes it
needs to be more like,
Girl, listen.
♪ We will, we will rock you ♪
♪♪
What's Ted doing?
Probably home sick.
Closest thing he can find to a
Dodge Ram.
Woohoo!
♪♪
Back home, if a team was playing
poorly, we don't call them
unlucky.
What do we call them, Coach?
New York Jets.
♪♪